There are 24 hours in a day, and on October
27th, 2017, that's not going to be enough.
For pop culture junkies, the last Friday in
October is shaping up to be one of the busiest
and most exciting release days in recent memory.
You've got new video game releases.
You have a brand new season of one of the
most binge-worthy shows on television.
You have an entire slate of geek-friendly
feature films making their long-awaited debuts.
The hard part is choosing which one to go
after first.
After all, you only have so much time — and
on days like this, every second is precious.
Here's why.
Stranger Things Season 2
The first season of Stranger Things practically
perfected the art of the cliffhanger, and
the finale ended on a doozy: Will Byers, fresh
off his adventures in the Upside Down, excuses
himself to go wash his hands — and promptly
vomits a slug into the bathroom sink.
On October 27th, we'll find out what that
means.
Netflix will release all nine episodes of
Stranger Things' sophomore effort at once,
giving fans plenty to chew on as they unravel
the show's lingering mysteries while getting
tangled up in all new ones.
Expect some answers, and even more questions,
alongside all of the '80s nostalgia you can
handle, when Stranger Things returns.
Just don't expect to see poor Barb this time
around.
Assassin's Creed Origins
Over the past nine games plus a handful of
spin-offs, Assassin's Creed has tracked the
Assassin vs Templar conflict through the centuries.
In the 2017 installment, we're going all the
way back to the beginning.
On October 27th, Assassin's Creed Origins
will drop players into a vibrant, open-world
recreation of ancient Egypt.
Sure, you'll still be scaling buildings — and
in this case, some pyramids — and sneaking
up on foes.
But despite the ancient setting, Origins is
shaping up to be the most modern Assassin's
Creed yet.
Instead of climbing towers, you can dispatch
an eagle to scout out the land around you.
Camels join horses and boats as methods of
transportation.
Combat is getting a Dark Souls-inspired overhaul,
while a Destiny-like loot system will make
exploring Assassin's Creed Origins' massive
open world much more satisfying.
Wolfenstein 2: The New Colossus
Bethesda will once again allow gamers to partake
in some fascist-smashing action this fall
with the release of Wolfenstein 2: The New
Colossus.
Like the 2016 DOOM reboot, 2014's Wolfenstein:
The New Order took the best elements from
older Wolfenstein games and gussied them up
for a discerning modern audience.
The New Colossus looks like it's going to
be more of the same — just, y'know, better.
Hero B.J.
Blazkowicz returns on October 27th, ready
to take the fight to America's Nazi occupiers
yet again.
Like its predecessor, The New Colossus will
feature old-school gameplay — no auto-regenerating
health here — and alternate spins on iconic
American locations, including Roswell, New
Mexico and a bombed-out New York City.
Professor Marston & the Wonder Women
The backstory for comics icon Wonder Woman
doesn't hold a candle to that of her creator,
Dr. William Marston.
Not only did Marston, a trained psychiatrist,
help invent the polygraph, but he believed
that women were naturally better than men,
and that true happiness could only be found
by giving in to "loving submission," literally
— the guy was big into BDSM.
Marston was also one-third of a polyamorous
relationship between himself, his wife Elizabeth,
and their partner, Olive.
All in all, there's tons of drama to mine
from Marson's life, even before the rope-wielding,
lie-detecting Wonder Woman gets involved.
If Professor Marston & the Wonder Women delivers
on its potential on October 27th, it should
be an even better origin story than the Amazon's
big-budget counterpart from earlier in the
year.
Jigsaw
Saw's signature villain met his demise at
the end of Saw III, and the rest of the series
is carried on by his proteges, who consider
themselves responsible for continuing Jigsaw's
good works.
But is that changing?
In the upcoming Jigsaw, bodies start piling
up.
And according to the evidence, Jigsaw himself
is responsible.
There's just one problem: he's been dead for
10 years.
Even without Jigsaw's brand-name appeal, that's
a compelling set-up for a mystery, and should
be enough to get gore-hounds of all types
into theaters when Jigsaw premieres on October
27th.
The series' brutal traps will return, but
with a new and updated tone that the director
says is "not quite as vicious and more fun,"
as well as a few plot twists primed to blow
audiences away.
Super Mario Odyssey
In March, it was hard to imagine that the
Nintendo Switch would get a better game in
2017 than The Legend of Zelda: Breath of the
Wild.
Then, Mario happened.
In Super Mario Odyssey, Nintendo's plucky
plumber ditches the Mushroom Kingdom for strange
new worlds, where he'll hunt for the Power
Moons that fuel his extradimensional ship.
In Odyssey's biggest gameplay twist, Mario
can hurl his hat — which is now a living
being named Cappy — onto friends and enemies
alike, possessing them and taking their powers.
The hat-tossing mechanic was everything that
Odyssey needed to walk away victorious at
E3 2017, but there's more to the game than
that.
Like Super Mario 64 and Super Mario Sunshine,
Super Mario Odyssey emphasizes exploration
over progression, with more collectibles to
find than any other game in the series.
The levels, meanwhile, look to be the most
diverse collection of settings in Mario history.
All that, and Bowser rocks an all-white tuxedo
and top hat, like some kind of big, scaly,
fancy lizard-man.
Can October 27th just get here already?
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!